let's say i had the reaction where i had
some
copper ions
they have a positive charge
of two and it's in an aqueous solution
there could be some other negative ions
in that solution actually we could talk
about that in a little bit but we know
that when you have these ions in
solution they all disassociate so you
just have to know you have a bunch of
ions just floating around in water there
could be some other negative ones to
neutralize the entire solution but let's
just worry about the positive ones for
now and in that solution
in that solution i'm going to put a bar
of zinc
i'm going to put a bar of zinc
and what happens is is that they
essentially switch places
they essentially switch places is that
the copper wants to jump out of your
aqueous solution i should probably draw
this so let me actually actually let me
draw it so let me have a
this is my solution
and in my solution this is let me make
it
blue because it's aqueous so most of it
is water i have some
copper molecules here
in the solution there are plus two
charge
plus two charge i could have some other
ions that are negative like some some
nitrate ions or whatever but they're all
disassociated and they're all mixing
around with the water molecules that are
polar and that's why ions disassociate
or salts in general disassociate well in
water
and i stick a bar of zinc in it solid
zinc so let me do that
i could use
so i stick a bar of solid zinc into it
and so what this reaction says is that
these copper ions they they if they can
get a hold of some electrons
if they can get a hold of some electrons
and be and and essentially become
neutral
they would rather
go back into the solid state
and the molecules of zinc out here
that are in the solid state if they can
lose some electrons they want to jump
into the solution so let me write down
the whole reaction so if the the copper
can get some electrons they're going to
go into the solid state
copper will go into the solid state and
if the zinc can lose some of electrons
they'll become they'll become positive
ions or cations
and then they will go into the solution
plus
i'll do the same color plus
zinc
plus two plus
aqueous
and actually just so a little side note
here these are actual ions we've been
dealing with oxidation numbers and when
you have when you want to know the
oxidation number of an ion the oxidation
number is the same thing as its charge
because it's no longer hypothetical
remember oxidation numbers were
hypothetical charges if a bond were
ionic in this case they are ionic so the
oxidation state or the oxidation number
is the same as a charge and just as a
side note the the convention if it's
written two plus this means that this is
a real charge if it's written plus two
at least this is the way i learned it
maybe there's different conventions in
different places then it would be an
oxidation state which says oh it's not
necessarily an ion but this is what it
would be if it was an ion so someone
writes plus two this is
oxidation state
if they write two plus they say hey this
is a real charge and likewise if you if
you just have a regular ion that has
like a charge of one so let's say you
have na
n a plus this means that it's an actual
charge if you wanted to write its
oxidation state you would write plus one
small little node it doesn't probably
make a big difference in the whole
scheme of things but sometimes it can
get confusing whether something is an
oxidation state or an ion but depending
on where you're going to school and what
your teachers or conventions are you
might want to clarify that and just make
sure that they use the same conventions
that at least i remember
when i first learned it so anyway let's
go back to this reaction that's
happening here so let's let's do the
half reactions for this so we start here
and actually we can just look at the
oxidation states to begin with this guy
has an oxidation he has a charge of two
which is also an oxidation number of two
and he goes to a neutral charge so
clearly he he gains two electrons which
means that he was reduced he went from a
positive charge to a zero oxidation
state or charge so his charge was
reduced let me write that
so this guy was reduced
and let me write his half reaction
he essentially he started off with some
copper in the aqueous state
aqueous state
and he got two electrons that's how you
get reduced so plus two electrons and he
ended up in the solid state
of copper and his oxidation number is
now zero
now let's see what happened to the zinc
the zinc
and it starts completely neutral in the
solid state no extra electrons or or
or or deficiency of electrons but then
once he jumps into the solution and once
the zinc jumps into the solution here he
has a charge so he must have lost
electrons so the half reaction for zinc
in this situation you have zinc as a
solid
and he reacts
to to produce two electrons
two electrons and
and then be left with just a
b and then he's in the water and he's
now an ion so let me put that there an
aqueous solution
so if we did this if we did this
experiment right here and i and i will
tell you right now this reaction moves
forward this is truly a reaction we're
going to talk about in a second how
badly do the electrons essentially want
to jump from
where they jumping from they're jumping
from the zinc
to
the copper so we're going to talk a
little bit about how strongly they want
to jump in the voltage and voltage is
really just how badly
does charge want to move or how much
potential energy does charge have
but this whole reaction just have to
think about what's happening is that you
have charge moving from as the zinc
jumps into the water
as the zinc jumps into the aqueous
solution it's passing on some charge to
the copper that jumps into the solid
form
so electrons are moving electrons are
moving here and if somehow we could
harness this move these moving electrons
we could create a current in this
situation it's all chemical the
electrons are moving around but they're
not doing it in any organized way
because the solution is all mixed up but
this is an interesting situation we're
dealing here and we can even talk about
how badly the electrons want to want to
move in these directions you can look at
these half reactions you can look it up
in a table and you can get these
energies or the voltages for these
reactions
and this half reaction right here
has a voltage
so they'll sometimes write e sometimes
it's an e naught right over there but
that's kind of out of the scope of at
least a first year chemistry course but
they'll say it's point three four volts
and then this reaction in this direction
has a potential difference
the energy is
0.76 volts if i wrote this in the other
way if i wrote this reaction of zinc
plus two electrons going to zinc solid
then i would have then you would just
switch the sine but what this says is is
that this state
this state right here
is a higher energy than that state so it
wants to go in that direction and it
wants to do that with a with a with an
energy per coulomb and i you can watch
the physics playlist on more details of
volts but volts units are joules per
coulomb this is how badly it want the
the
want to join the copper that's the best
way of viewing it and this is a measure
of how badly the electrons want to leave
the zinc
so if you wanted to talk about this
whole reaction so this whole reaction
that we have up here we could say it's
an energy
so the
the energy of this entire reaction up
here
we know that electrons really want to
join the copper with this energy and
they really want to leave the zinc with
this energy so the the energy of this
entire reaction how badly do electrons
want to
move from zinc to copper to form this
over there is just the sum of the two so
you get what's 1.1 volts
and all you're probably saying hey sal
all this talk of volts this is
interesting and current is there some
way that we could construct a battery or
a a a galvanic cell if you don't know
what a galvanic cell is it's well it's
what we're going about to construct
right now and the answer is obviously
yes because that's the whole point of
this video so how can we somehow harness
that charge
so let's let's separate the two
reactions
let's separate the two so instead of so
let me put my
my copper no sorry my zinc
bar here
and let me put my i'll try to stay true
to the colors that i used earlier and
let me put my copper
bar there
actually maybe i should copy and paste
what i wrote up here just so we remember
the reaction itself
actually yeah let me do that
never hurts
okay i'll paste it down here you can
ignore all the squiggly lines around it
and let me put both of my bars in some
aqueous solution
and there could be some other dissolved
ions in there to help neutralize the
different
so i put them both in an aqueous
solution
but they're separate
they're separate
and let me label them appropriately
so this is my
zinc
zinc right here borrows solid zinc and
this is my bar of solid copper i should
do it in a different color so this is
copper right here
my bar of solid copper and then i have
an aqueous solution
so what happens if we were to connect
these two metals right they're metals if
we look at the periodic table they're
both uh depending how you cut they're
both transition metals they both have
the sea of electrons so they both
conduct electricity well what happens if
you conduct if you if you connect these
two with a wire
so if i connect them with a wire
right here like that
we already know that the zinc is just
dying to jump into the water and lose
its electrons right so let's say that
there that the that happens so the zinc
jumps into the aqueous solution
and it turns into
a positive ion of zinc and then its
electrons are left behind
right so it essentially has two
electrons i drew i did the half reaction
right here right the zinc jumps into the
solution and it leaves behind
two electrons right here so one electron
two electrons here they really want to
jump off of the zinc
now i have a lot of
copper out of here out here in the
solution
that really want to jump onto this bar
of copper
right but right now they're all ions
these are all plus two ions
plus
these are all plus two ions and they
really wanna jump onto the bar and join
all of these other
copper ions here but in order to to jump
onto that they have to they have to get
some electrons each of these guys have
to grab two electrons and we know the
kind of the
the the potential or or the the
electromotive force with which they want
to grab those electrons
is
0.34 volts
right these guys want to jump here and
grab electrons from some place with
point plus 0.34 volts these guys want to
jump off of the bar and leave their
electrons behind with 0.7 what was it
0.7
0.76 volts
so what do you think's going to happen
if we have a conducting wire here well
those electrons
are once this zinc just jumps off those
electrons are going to travel through
the wire
and then they're going to be available
because these are surplus electrons to
merge with these these copper ions that
want to jump back onto the onto the bar
so these copper ions are going to jump
back onto the bar and but from this
reaction what's happening you're having
a current flow
current is actually flowing and what is
the voltage across this how badly does
an electron want to go
from this zinc on this bar to over here
join with some copper in the solution
and let that copper join onto that bar
it wants to do it with
plus 1.1 volts now the question is the
electrons are flowing in that way what
is the cathode and what is the anode
so the cathode
the cathode
is the is the positive terminal of well
since we're you can already imagine this
is a a battery of sorts right because we
are able to generate a current by having
a voltage difference across two
terminals the cathode is the positive
terminal it's the positive terminal
that's where the electrons want to go to
and then the anode
anode and you can familiarize yourself
this with you know just the the you know
a cation is a positive ion an anion is a
negative ion so the anode is the
negative terminal
so what's the negative terminal here the
negative terminals where the electrons
come from so electrons are coming from
these zincs jumping off so so here this
is your negative terminal and what's the
positive terminal that's where the
electrons want to go to they want to go
down here and and and and and be
available for these coppers that want to
jump out of the solution so this is our
positive
this is our positive terminal or our
cathode this is the cathode this is the
anode
and if you if someone says hey does
oxidation or reduction occur at the
cathode or the anode well what's
occurring right here we have zinc
in its solid state right here
we have solid zinc jumping in and it's
neutral and it jumps into the solution
and it leaves two electrons behind so
it's losing electrons when you lose
electrons you're being oxidized so this
is where the oxidation is occurring
likewise on this side you have copper
ions that are already in the solution
and they are gaining electrons so their
charge is being reduced so the cathode
is where reduction is taking place
reduction
now you're probably saying oh sal this
is a nice cute little you know
a battery or or this is called a
galvanic cell that you know you've
created this current but i see a problem
here because as this happens you're
going to have more and more positive
zinc ions
jump into the solution here
you have more and more positive zinc
ions in here as this progresses
and you're going to have fewer and fewer
you're going to have fewer and fewer
copper ions in here so if you assume
that there were some other let's say
there was i mean maybe there were some
you know to the the the to keep this
solution neutral maybe you know there
was the copper is positive maybe you had
some chloride in there chloride anions
that were keeping it
that that we're keeping it um that we're
keeping this solution neutral and maybe
he had some chlorine anions here that
we're keeping that well it started
negative but then maybe it gets a little
bit more neutral as the zinc jumps in
but once this happens a lot then it
becomes very positive right this is
becoming more and more positive as more
and more zinc jumps in and this is
becoming more and more negative is more
copper jumps onto this bar so what can
we do to solve that problem
what they do is and this is just one way
to solve the problem there's actually
many but this is probably what you might
encounter in your first year chemistry
class is they create something called a
salt bridge
a salt bridge and what they do is they
create a i guess we could call it a
pseudo aqueous solution of a salt maybe
it is
uh you know maybe it's potassium
chloride
right so in here we have potassium
potassium has a plus charge it's aqueous
plus chlorine with a negative charge
aqueous and i say pseudo aqueous because
it's not really
super liquid water what they do is they
try to make it more viscous so it just
doesn't mix completely if this was pure
water then all of it would just fall
into this solution and you would really
have nothing up here would be a useless
device what they do is they create a
gel out of this that's still aqueous
enough that the ions can move around the
sodium and chloride ions can move around
so let's say that those are the
uh sorry not the sodium the potassium
let's say that's the potassium and let's
say the chlorine ions are i already did
it in that blues chlorine are the minus
and what happens is as we have this
oxidation reduction reaction that's
causing these electrons to travel from
the anode to the cathode this becomes
positive this becomes negative the salt
bridge allows the negative components of
the of the ionized salt and just waste
the chlorine to go into this solution to
neutralize it so they'll end up having
more and more chlorine as the zinc pops
off
so you can kind of you know if you were
to evaporate the solution you'd end up
with a bunch of zinc chloride and on
this side to keep to keep the balance
here you'll have a lot of the pot the
positive
parts components of the salt so the
sodium would jump in to replace the
copper that's jumping out so when you
have this whole thing it enables the
current to keep flowing without having a
bad effect on the charge because you
know what what happens if this becomes
really positive if this becomes really
positive i'll do it a vibrant color
because there's no salt bridge
at some point the electrons are going to
say hey i can either go over here and
drive this reaction or hey i got a lot
of positive stuff hanging out here maybe
i don't want to leave at all so you have
to do something to neutralize the charge
here likewise if this becomes really
negative from all of the chlorine atoms
jumping out
electrons aren't going to want to go
here because the
like charges repel each other so that's
what having the salt bridge neutralizing
the solution does for you it keeps it
from getting negative and then our
galvanic cell can keep operating